conduit le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov a donné une
conférence de presse est là réagissent
et notamment la question concernant la
sphère navalni il n'a pas mâché ses mots
en réussissant à la question justement
au supposé impose à nous de le pose en
russe alexeï navalni pour le ministre
russe cela ressemble à une nouvelle
affaire skripal rien de moins
la rappeler que les résultats de leur
enquête sur l'empoisonnement de l'ex
espion russe sergueï skripal et sa fille
yulia sont restés secrets et la russie
ne possède toujours pas d'information
sur la sphère c1 a tout de même pas
empêcher l'introduction d'une série de
sanctions à l'égard de la russie
les récents développements dans la
sphère navalni laisse penser à une
répétition du même scénario
je vous propose d'écouter un extrait de
la conférence de presse du cervia
launcher aux coyotes
nous n'avons rien à cacher je tiens à
rappeler encore une fois qu aussitôt qu
alexeï navalni s'est senti mal
lorsqu'ils étaient à bord de l'avion des
mesures immédiates ont été prises pour
faire atterrir l'avion à l'aéroport une
ambulance l'attendait déjà où il a été
immédiatement conduit à l'hôpital et
placé sous ventilation artificielle
toutes les autres mesures nécessaires
ont été prises sauf si rodrigue inapte
résumé alex et ya passé un peu plus d'un
jour et demi
si je comprends bien tout ce temps on
exigé chaque heure de raconter
immédiatement ce qui s'était passé et de
montrer de fournir des informations
acquises et puis une fois qu'il a été
transféré en allemagne pendant plus
d'une semaine où aucun de ceux qui avait
fait grand bruit de son séjour à omsk
personne n'a rien demandé et n'a exigé
des médecins allemands qui fournissent
des informations et nous n'avons
toujours pas des informations produits
ce que coûte une formation et modric
pour le confort - sont inhumés sergueï
lavrov s'est dit sceptique par rapport
aux accusations dans la sphère navale né
l'a réitéré que la russie attendait
toujours à ce que les filles soient
présentés pour lui l'attitude politique
arrogante méprisante montre que les
partenaires occidentaux ne sont pas
capables de montrer rien de concret